well it had to happen eventually the
frustration from being
unable to send out his screeds and
diatribes via twitter was going to get
to former president donald trump
and there's a report from the daily
beast
that trump is so frustrated from being
unable to uh send out insults on twitter
because he's banned
uh that he's been writing down insults
and giving them to aids and asking them
to tweet the messages out this is being
reported
uh by the daily beast sources close to
trump
said to the daily beast that uh trump
was really really upset i'm so wound up
about the story i
just threw my sharpie the entire liz
cheney thing where there was a
referendum within the republican party
about liz cheney and whether she should
retain her leadership role or not and
uh you might recall that liz cheney was
one of the ten republicans in the house
that
um back in january voted
to impeach donald trump in the house of
representatives now leading to his
upcoming
second impeachment trial and this entire
time
trump couldn't tweet he was desperate to
tweet he was desperate to attack his
political
opponents and what is being reported is
that trump has quote
written out insults and observations
several of them about liz cheney i
assume summer about her physical
appearance
because it's trump uh and has resorted
to suggesting
put-downs for others to use or post to
their own
twitter accounts and uh i mean this is
you know it's it's it's so ridiculous
and childish but completely obvious that
you know i was thinking trump trump
almost seems more upset about not being
able to tweet
than he is about not being president
anymore and then i thought well
he might actually believe he still is
the rightful president because he
believes it was supposedly stolen by joe
biden
trump seems to know he's definitely
banned from twitter
i have this image of trump sitting at
mar-a-lago or wherever he is i don't
even know
with construction paper and crayons but
not the thin crayons the fat ones were
like it's impossible to write anything
coherently
sitting there writing out insults with
one of the fat crayons and a piece of
construction paper and seeing who might
be willing to tweet it out
i think we'll know if trump's written uh
screeds
are getting out on twitter like if we
see stephen miller tweet
that little marco rubio isn't really a
patriot or something about ted cruz's
wife's physical appearance we'll know
that it's probably not really stephen
miller tweeting it's probably actually
donald trump
and as we observed during the presidency
this is a man trump who seems to have
like a bottomless reflex or a desire
to just insult people it comes so
naturally to him and a lot of it
from what we know seems to come from
from his childhood and the way he was
raised and
the relationship with his dad not to get
all all freudian
um and uh it's it's really the type of
pathetic behavior that just reminds us
again that this guy never had the
temperament to be
president of the united states and we
think back to hillary clinton during the
debates in 2016 who said this man is
temperamentally unfit to be president
and of course she was completely right
um and
uh for the last uh
what was it few weeks i guess month or
so of trump
being on twitter more than
more than half certainly i don't know
what percentage of his tweets were being
labeled either misleading
or were restricted by twitter for either
spreading conspiracy theories or
making false claims about elections or
whatever the case may be
and now we are seeing a real rift in the
republican party
where you have lawmakers who want to
completely get rid of even
trump almost like erase trump from
history
and get rid of his influence and then
you have this other side
the marjorie taylor green lauren bobert
side
that seems determined to keep trumpism
going to trump to some degree
and that's what led to this movement
within the republican party to try to
remove congresswoman
liz cheney an anti-trump
or at least a trump skeptical republican
from a position of power
it failed it failed and throughout all
of this donald trump
uh reportedly very pleased with marjorie
taylor green
desperate to get somebody to tweet out
the insults that he's been coming up
with so
i i don't know what else to tell you but
trump behaving exactly as we would
expect him to behave this is very very
interesting
many republicans have been demanding
smaller
packages from democrats as we talked
about yesterday
gen saki regularly reminded of the fact
that all these different republicans say
biden's package is too big they need a
smaller uh package
mitt romney is doing something very
interesting mitt romney is a republican
senator
he has a proposal to provide three
thousand dollars per child to millions
of american families and this would be
a form of bipartisan support for joe
biden's
coveted relief plan which includes
expanding child
benefits now it's a slightly different
framework romney would give 4 200
per year per child up to age six
that goes down to three thousand dollars
per year per child for age six to
seventeen
and um how that would interact with some
of these other
elements uh is in the details that that
we are still
learning about but what is very
interesting about this
is that one of the reasons that mitt
romney
and maybe some other republicans are
interested in this
is that they think if you give these
bigger
payments uh to people they will be less
likely to uh file
uh or right no i'm sorry let me go
backwards
uh republicans believe that
giving payments would discourage parents
from finding jobs and this is their
concern with what
mitt romney and also with with what joe
biden are proposing
this is this very old trope that we hear
from the right
which is predicated on the idea that
everybody's lazy
and nobody has any drive or motivation
and people just want to figure out how
to not work at all
most people you know there's an
evolutionary
thing to this and when we i've read some
very interesting articles about
you know people who feel unfulfilled and
all these different things
there are practical reasons for that
people seeking meaning and fulfillment
but there may also be an evolutionary
reason which is when you were
fulfilled human advancement potentially
stopped when you were
satisfied you stopped trying to improve
your circumstances and those of
your children and their children and so
on so there may even be an evolutionary
basis for this but
most people want to do something most
people want meaning yes
there are some people who for a variety
of different reasons
want the easiest path out if i can just
sit at home and not work and collect
money that's fine
most people don't want that most people
want
one job that pays well so that they can
have some meaning coming from employment
and also have the financial wherewithal
um
to be able to raise kids put food on the
table for family
participate in life in other ways and
this republican idea
that if you do this it always assumes
the worst about people's intentions and
the worst about
humanity and that's really how these
republicans see people but i'm glad to
see mitt romney proposing
um proposing an alternative to this now
this is going to be the the way that
romney's idea would be integrated is
that mitt romney
wants it to be an amendment to the
democratic budget resolution
and uh it looks as though a budget of
resolution budget reconciliation is
increasingly likely to be
the way that this coveted relief bill is
going to be passed and as i've said
before
the fact that democrats can pass this
without
any republican involvement to me signals
the time for so-called negotiation with
republicans is over
but i don't believe every republican
will vote against it i believe that
there are
republicans that either for personal
political convictions
or because of their their realization
that coveted relief is popular with
their constituents
some republicans are going to vote for
this and uh put
call them on their bluff right see if
they actually are all going to vote
against
the 1.9 trillion dollar package if
that's what democrat democrats go
forward with
i don't believe that they will and in
particular now with mitt romney jumping
in which
makes this listen i always thought it
was naive to think you're going to get
this big bipartisan
coveted relief bill when the party of
republicans is the party of obstruction
but merely mitt romney saying here's an
idea and then i'm in favor of it
it makes it technically bipartisan even
if nobody else comes on board so i think
these are very very
interesting developments and to be very
clear i know there are people who keep
writing to me saying davey boy
why aren't you calling out biden for the
fact that he said 2 000 and now it's
1400 and why aren't you calling out
biden for the fact that he said the
checks would go out right away and they
haven't i have called him out
i called him out in just about every
segment i've done including on
yesterday's show
joe biden has already not done what he
promised which is he said it would be
two thousand dollars not
to not fourteen hundred to get to a
total of two thousand with the last
stimulus joe biden said two thousand
dollar checks
now they're talking about fourteen
hundred that's already a problem
joe biden also said if democrats win the
two seats in georgia
checks go out right away well it's
already
february i understand this takes a
little bit of time but
it's time to move forward it's time to
do it with budget reconciliation whether
or not republicans
want to be involved and i hope i mean
listen if mitt romney proposing even
more money for children is the way to
make it bipartisan and get more
republicans
to support it great if not it's time for
democrats to get it done by themselves
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at d pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21 all one word all lowercase
become a member today
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's hear from some folks in
the audience via the david pakman show
discord which you can find at
davidpakman.com
discord let's start today with uh
james from new york is that is this is
this james md
from new york are you a doctor
oh boy james oh yeah
how are you good how are you
i'm doing well yeah um so i called in
before sort of asking about why it seems
like this whole government seems to be
missing the force for the trees i
thought you gave a great answer
um i have a question for you about
it seems like biden is just sort of
entering the game
trying to play let's be friends with
everybody let's
show unity almost like letting the
republicans
sort of like undercut his positions you
know give less for covid
not do basically the best for the
american you know person
and why doesn't biden just ram all these
things down their throats
to basically get the general public to
be like wow
my health insurance is better my
food is better and cheaper i actually
did get money
under biden why does he seem to want to
compromise on all this stuff to pretend
like there's unity
when the republicans are in power they
put all the supreme court justices on
and say
tough break you lost the election well i
think we still need a little more time
to know which path he's taking
you're completely right that joe biden
has been talking about unity
he invited republicans to the white
house to meet about the coveted bill on
monday night
i am fine with biden talking about unity
and talking to republicans if as you say
in the end he just goes forward
and from what we heard after that monday
meeting from gensake the white house
press secretary
democrats are just planning to move
ahead with the covid relief bill as
designed with the 1.9 trillion
i believe it's actually perfect if
biden eventually is just going to say
we're sticking with the 1.9
and it's what democrats go for put these
republicans in a position to actually
vote no on it because that coveted
relief bill is popular with many
republican voters tens of millions of
republican voters
i don't believe call the bluff of the
republicans i don't believe
that every republican is going to vote
against the 1.9 trillion
because they know many of their
constituents want that and they like
that bill
so if what joe biden does is talk about
unity
talk about compromise meet with
republicans and then not go
forward with the 1.9 i will be as pissed
as it sounds like you're going to be
if this is all just biden doing what he
said he would do
but then he's still going to stick to
what he wants i'm fine with it
we'll probably know in the next few days
which of the two it's going to be
yeah that's pretty fair i just i would
rather him he could play the
let's have unity together but i just
think he needs to ram
these policies down their throats to
show you know the average american
especially you know it seems like the
biggest class that's voting conservative
these days
is uneducated voters that just to show
them here's the proof in the pudding
here's your money here
i got you i gotcha yeah i don't disagree
let's uh let's see if he does it
james from new york appreciate the call
thank you so much
let's go next to terence from gloucester
terence from gloucester you're on the
air hi david how's it going uh can you
hear me okay i can hear you fine
uh so i don't know if you remember me
but we spoke a couple of months ago when
i called in under the single-letter
pseudonym
t to talk about the decent federalism
project
which was my project on twitter at
decent fed
eroj to advocate for distributing some
power
currently held by the federal government
down to a five-part framework of regions
of the u.s
is i know you take a lot of calls but uh
do you roughly remember
our conversation or anything we talked
about
okay awesome uh so the youtube video on
your channel i think is
called uh should the country be divided
into regions
and i think it's still a worthy video
for people to check out
um but so i remember from our
conversation
uh and correct me if i'm wrong i
understood you as having said
towards the end of our discussion that
you were open at least in principle to a
more
regional approach to governance in the
united states does that sound like a
fair characterization of what you said i
i don't remember exactly but did you
have a question today
yeah so so i guess my big question is
whether you see the events
of like recent uh days recent months
uh as affirming or complicating the idea
of
regionalizing our system of governance
in the way we've discussed before in
terms of
you know the stop the steel the the 17
uh
state attorneys general from the south
and central parts of the country that
um basically wanted to overturn the
election
um as well as sort of the coalition that
uh joe biden built
uh for to win the election i i have to
tell you i don't think the events of the
last few months
um to me suggest that uh
regionalization for governance would be
better or worse i don't i don't think it
really strikes me as something to think
about in those terms one way or the
other
okay fair enough and that's that was
really my only question david
all right very good terence from
gloucester great to hear from you
again uh let's go next
to dave from brooklyn dave from brooklyn
you're on the air
dave from brooklyn you're on the air
please unmute and we can chat
hey can you hear me yes i can hey um i'm
a big big first time caller big time fan
thank you video yesterday on youtube
about
right-wing uh rash uh radicalization and
media and how they're gonna keep
one-upping each other and so on and so
forth i was
thinking about how as uh because i have
a few i come from a community
in los angeles a wealthier community
where most of my friends growing up
are trump supporters most of the family
members
that i have except for my parents are
trump supporters and so on and so forth
and
um i'm just baffled by
the fact that on the left we keep
fighting this we keep trying to fight
this fight where we
keep also trying to one-up each other
with our uh who's
more correct who's more liberal who's
more appropriate who's who cares more
about race who cares more about
gender who cares more about all this
other stuff rather than getting things
done rather than having an agenda
that tries to actually progressively
pass policies
that will improve the lives of americans
well let's separate out some of those
because
you know when you say when you talk
about who's most liberal as an example
yeah there's no doubt that there is a
movement based around virtue signaling
gatekeeping
and litmus testing around what qualifies
you
as being more liberal or liberal enough
and that's probably not a productive
movement
who's most correct to me does not sound
like it's under the same category
i think that that should be one of the
top priorities let's figure out
what is most correct what policies are
actually the
most useful and beneficial so i don't
know that i'd wrap all of that together
necessarily
maybe i wasn't using my words actually
but i meant the reason why i
uh thought about this is because when it
came to this whole gamestop
fiasco with all the uh with robin hood
and everything that's going on i have a
lot of friends on the left who are
really they're really having they're
really upset about what's going on when
they don't really understand the
what's going on on the back end i have
friends or engineers at robin hood my
wife's an engineer at a financial
company i used to be a software engineer
myself
and you know from a technical
perspective there are of course
somewhat corrupt things going on at a
higher level but from a technical and
financial perspective it makes a lot of
sense what these companies have done
um from a policy perspective and
shutting down trading at least in the
beginning
and they know when we come and we get
all mad about it when we're not really
educated as a liberal populist
the entire left wing majority we're not
all educated on
what goes on in the back end no that's
certainly true and i've read some of the
technical defenses of why uh
why the ability to purchase was
curtailed or suspended but
if that is i i i what my position after
reading more about it is that
if that if we have a system in which
that is what is the correct
technical decision then there's a
broader problem with the system that
needs to be solved and listen
there's a noise coming through on your
end that's so bad i'm gonna have to let
you go
but i really do appreciate the uh
question and it's
it's an important issue uh for sure and
one one which we will
we will continue looking at uh very
strongly
let's go to bethany from oklahoma
bethany from oklahoma you're on the air
hi can you hear me yes i can oh
perfect um i
i actually hopped on here not i'm not
even realizing
you were filming i was just hoping to
catch you i
don't know what time you all start the
show
so i happened to hop on and i got called
this is crazy um
beautiful i guess my question is
um in the past few days you've been
talking about how
biden is being um being criticized for
all of his
executive orders yes and we've talked
about how
you know he's doing what people want him
to do um but the critique i'm seeing
from
you know liberal friends is that since
we control
the house and the senate now why isn't
he
going about it through legislation
because he doesn't necessarily
have to get republicans on board does he
so a couple of thoughts usually what you
say
this is an important question so there's
a few different things bethany first of
all
if the things joe biden uh uh
if joe biden is dealing with actual
emergencies via executive order
then you have to do it as quickly as
possible and so
if if we agree some of these things have
to be changed
right away and i agree that some of the
things that
that biden did via executive order do
have to be changed right away
you do the executive order and then you
try to get a more permanent
legislative infrastructure in the next
two years during which joe biden will
have
um the control of the house and senate
so i that
that argument the idea that you don't
need to do any executive orders
because you have control and you can do
it all that that that's not a good
argument number one because if you have
an actual emergency you need to deal
with it as quickly as possible
number two not everything can be done
with a simple majority
uh there are things that that require 60
votes
in the senate in order to get done and
so it's not quite so simple now with
something like coveted relief
i'm ready for biden to stop the meetings
with republicans it was fine to do the
meeting
it was fine to listen to republicans who
want 600 billion instead of 1.9 trillion
but you can use budget reconciliation to
pass covid relief with a simple majority
and it's time to do it so i think that
any you know anytime you hear
such a general critique bethany like
biden doesn't need to do any executive
orders because he has the house and
senate and can just do everything
legislatively
it's such a general assessment that it
almost certainly
it falls short as an analysis and that's
exactly the case it's much more
complicated than that
yeah that makes sense and and i had
forgotten that part about you know of
course
things some things require more than a
simple majority that is
absolutely accurate and it takes time
and it takes time i mean
the even even without republican
obstruction
a lot of these things do have to go
through committee
and and you know i'm not defending the
the speed at which the covet stuff is
being done
i would have liked to see biden do the
meeting with republicans on january
22nd and we could already be moving
beyond it but
i understand why he's giving them a
meeting it now it's just time to act and
get it done
yep and i i like what you said about um
you know
if if it's true that they want to follow
up some of this stuff
with legislation um that does have a
longer
uh you know hold then that that makes
more sense too and that is what i will
um come back with when i hear that
talking point yeah i mean the critique
that in general
executive orders are a problem because
the next president can just undo it
that's always been a critique that's
that's not that's not uh different than
something that could be said
in the past it doesn't really change
whether for the time being that
executive orders can be done
joe biden is right or wrong to use them
gotcha well thank you yeah that's really
all i
i'm mainly just listening but i did have
that question that's been popping in my
head while i've
been watching your show um this week so
all right thanks bethany bethany from
oklahoma
uh great to hear from you and uh hope to
hear from you
again let's go uh why don't we go next
oh there's just so many people who are
interested in uh
in getting on today why don't we go to
sean from college station
yes i can my apologies i had my keyboard
on the floor
oh my how does the keyboard even get on
the floor uh
i have a small son and he loves to uh
play with my keyboard oh gotcha all
right well what's going on
uh not too much um so i had a quick
question
um i've asked it a couple times before
but i know you get tons of questions
um how would you feel about trying
a medicare for all in the same way that
they're doing the
electoral vote compact so for example
as we know the states uh
are signing up and once we get to a
certain number of states or certain
number of electoral votes
that's when the the law will kick in uh
i hear a lot of people complain
with medicare for all on the state level
that oh well then a bunch of people are
just going to move to that state
and you're going to have you know it's
going to be so
overloaded in that state that there's no
way
any one state could handle it so what if
what would you feel about like maybe
some sort of interstate vote
or interstate compact where okay once we
have a certain number of the population
you know so there's a couple different
there's a couple different
issues there okay the first one is
because you know the national population
national popular
uh vote interstate compact is not really
analogous to what you're suggesting with
medicare for all
because it it it's just a completely
different thing
there's no way that if enough states do
medicare for all you all of a sudden
have
federal medicare for all i think the
idea of
starting medicare for all within one
state is a great idea vermont
tried to do it a few years ago and they
ultimately were not able to
um the the question of people moving to
that state
it'll become a problem more because of
the supply of medical services
financially it shouldn't be a problem
because if people move to that state
they'll be paying taxes to the state
which will support the program okay so
that that's the concern is less about
people moving
from a financial standpoint it's that
it'll create demand for way more doctors
and presumably some doctors will move
there as well so let's keep thinking
about that i'm going to let you go
because it really sounds like you have
your hands very very full there with
your son
uh very much appreciate the call let's
take a quick break
if you're holding don't hang up because
we're going
right back to the phones momentarily the
david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at
slash patreon.com pakman show this is
audience supported media we depend on
the support of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
david pakman show
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
all right let's hear from a few more
folks via the david pakman show discord
server which you can find
at davidpakman.com
discord let's go to trudy from
glasgow trudy you're on the air
hi david how are you i'm very good
thanks how are you
i'm doing well i just wanted to phone up
and uh thank you very much for the
common sense that you bring to things
my pleasure um it's just very nice to
hear your point of view
obviously living in scotland we're back
in a full lockdown at the moment so
um we're all staying at home i
work at a primary school for five to 12
year olds
yes i'm still at work um but everyone
else is at home
so how are things looking from the
standpoint of vaccination
um at the moment i think in scotland
we're
just sending out letters for the over
60s
to get an appointment for vaccination
that's interesting it's being
done by uh paper letters are being sent
out that's i've not heard of that before
yes yeah you get uh you get an
appointment
um to go to your local vaccination
center
interesting and is that is it going more
slowly than people would like i mean i
guess no matter what it's going more
slowly than people would like but
yeah i mean it's certainly going more
slowly i think than i would like
um but obviously they're they're doing
all they can
or you hope or you presume that they're
doing all they can to get as many people
vaccinated as possible
of course yeah and is there uh how how
strong
is the anti-vaxx movement in scotland
it's not very strong it's not strong
enough that i'm aware of it oh that's
good that's good if you're not aware of
it that's a great start like i'm very
aware of it in the united states
right i mean i know of a few people who
have said oh
i'm i'm not sure if i'm going to get it
or not or
um but that really that's just a
personal point of view it's right
it's not really a whole movement have
you um
do you know people who have been
vaccinated my mom just had her first
dose
last week oh okay and side effects how
were they
nothing really she felt a little unwell
you know a bit of a headache for a
couple of days but that was all
wow yeah yeah i was down with a fever 36
hours i was shocked truly
wow right okay yeah no she had the the
oxford asked as anyone so
ah okay okay yeah that that one is not
currently available in the us
but um very it's great that that
there are so many vaccines now on the
precipice of approval
well good trudy i appreciate your
comments and hope uh hope
people get vaccinated soon thank you for
your time
my pleasure all right trudy from glasgow
what a polite perfect phone call
unbelievable let's go next to ivan
from phoenix arizona ivan you're on the
air
hi david how are you good um so i'm
currently
a senior in high school okay um and
recently i've been paying attention to
uh like the local elections
over here in i'm actually in gilbert um
but like also the politicians here and
uh i've realized that like a lot of them
are extremely slimy
um people i'm just curious how i can get
more involved to make sure that these
types of people aren't elected anymore
especially as arizona is becoming more
left-leaning
yeah i mean this you know pay attention
to
whether there is a candidate that you
find to be not slimy that runs
at the city council level mayoral level
whatever uh and work for their campaign
i mean there's no
all of these upstart campaigns want
volunteers
and if you don't see anybody who you
want to put your efforts behind
consider maybe running yourself at some
point but that's this is exactly the
right question you don't like the people
that are representing you
um and so you have you can have a voice
in that and that means not only can you
will you be able to vote i don't know if
you're you're already old enough to vote
not only will you be able to vote
you can run you can support other
candidates you can draft other
candidates and say to someone you should
really run against this person so yeah
the local level is where you can
actually
have the biggest and fastest impact in
many ways
yeah that's what i was thinking um last
year i had the opportunity to
go to the capitol um for like an
environmental day and speak with
uh the my con uh
my representative um and he just started
questioning like the sources our biology
books came from
oh my god yeah it was like an absolute
mess
um so i just want to make sure like
these types of people aren't
able to have any power you know i just
recently was reading
that the the most dangerous state to be
in from the standpoint of the pandemic
is arizona have you does that resonate
with you in terms of what you've seen
oh yeah it's a complete mess here um
people don't wear masks in stores like i
work at a walmart and
probably one third of the people aren't
wearing masks when they're inside
um schools nobody wears masks it's
it's just really bad here and how about
as far as vaccines are you hearing a lot
of anti-vaxx talk
um actually i haven't heard too much um
anti-vaxx talk
um just more so people still believing
that the virus
is just a democratic hoax
well the weird thing about that is you'd
think then it would have ended when joe
biden was sworn in
yeah i mean i my my uncle kept saying
that
come november 3rd the coronavirus is
going to be over
right okay here we are have you talked
to him and asked what happened uh
i haven't actually um we don't have the
strongest
uh relationship okay yeah i can guess
why yeah
yeah all right well listen ivan you're
asking all the right questions you're
doing all the right things it's great
that you're involved
well thank you very much david all right
ivan from phoenix
fantastic fantastic to have uh
young folks involved very very important
let's go to psy from texas psy from
texas you're on the air
david i just had a one question
yes please speak up sai so we can hear
you uh sure is this okay
yeah that's better uh yeah so what are
your thoughts on
i guess uh the democrats uh promising
two thousand dollar checks
and i guess flip-flopping to 1400 checks
instead
right i personally don't i would take
anything but i've seen a lot of uh
i guess criticism from mainly more the
left
like uh far left um
so i was just wondering i think it's a
fair criticism so listen i mean
when when they first started talking
about
the 1.9 trillion
you could more plausibly make the
argument that like listen they supported
2000
in december and since people got 600
another 1400 gets us to the total of 2
000. like okay i kind of get that but
at this point by the time people get any
money it'll probably be march it'll be
almost
four months later so i believe that it
should be 2
not not get us to a total of two
thousand i think it should just be
two thousand so i don't like it like you
i believe that
getting 1400 to people is still so much
better than nothing and hopefully cases
will continue coming down
the economy will start to recover etc
but i don't like it for me when when
they said 2
000 the way i understood it was 2 000
more
not 1400 to get us to a total of two
and so i don't i don't like it one bit
okay
yeah all right thank you so much
appreciate it thank you great to hear
from you
uh all right let's go next to
uh where do we want to go there's some
interesting folks and there's some
dangerous
folks to talk to let's briefly speak to
justin from the united kingdom justin
from the uk you're on there
hello do you hear me i do hear you hi
david good to speak to you likewise um i
was actually
born in chicago in the united states
okay um but i have
all my life in the uk so you've only it
seems like you've only taken on
a slight british accent yeah my dad's
american and i
listen to a lot of you fine american
folks so got it you know i think i've
adopted some of the
twang as it were
i was wondering when you guys are going
to sort out your shiz if you know what i
mean because
you know i'm living here in the uk i
have the paradise of uh
free health care whenever i want it
right
no problems and one day you know i'd
like to move to the us and uh
make good use of that citizenship that i
have but from the outside looking in
it's a bit like
in some in some ways it's a a bit of a
third world country
is it specifically the healthcare thing
that's what's making you hesitate
i guess it's a thought it's not not just
the healthcare it's the healthcare
it's the complete lack of paid vacation
days
let's say i have a family in the future
and i want to have a kid
i don't want to have to pay money to
have a child you know and have
potentially higher infant mortality
rates than i would have here
you mean when you so let me see if i
you're saying lack of paternity leave
not necessarily only pretend to leave
but i'm i'm speaking also for you know
the women of the world um and that any
partner i might have
would not be able to avail themselves of
that maternity leave and the
lack of paid vacation days is a serious
well hold on i mean maybe
maybe there's this is just a genuine
misunderstanding but you know the the
truth is that in the united states
things are very very much tiered
and there there are tiers of jobs where
uh there's plenty of paid vacation and
uh insurance is is good enough i mean
the problem is that there's such an
equality that you have neighborhoods
that are five miles apart
where the circumstances are dramatically
different for
i i hate to say this but if you were to
come to the united states
with a good job waiting for you you get
paid vacation
paid maternity leave uh relatively
modest health insurance contributions i
mean
what's horrible about the system is that
it does work quite well
for people in in certain jobs and it's
an absolute
embarrassing disaster for people and
others i i hate to admit that
um but you know depending on which
situation you were in it could be a
disaster or it could be fine i mean
that's what's so horrible
yeah i mean for me it would definitely
be the case i'd be able to get a decent
enough job to have
suitable health care at least for me
right but it's still just something you
have in the back of your mind you know
if your economy takes a downturn or
whatever and you don't have health
insurance at that time
absolutely what you do and it's just you
know it's a matter of writing out pros
and cons for living in different
countries
as we globalized people tend to do who
have the opportunity to move around and
work in different countries
right and you know when you're looking
at america compared to let's say the
netherlands or other places in europe
and you're ticking the boxes there's
just a lot of boxes left unticked on the
american side that kind of make it
look less appealing which i think is a
shame
no doubt about it i i completely
sympathize with you and
uh yeah i mean where in the uk are you
i'm in birmingham not alabama right
right
i've never been but but certainly the uk
has some uh
fantastic cities with high quality of
life and i uh i
understand why why people might hesitate
to abandon that
okay uh all right we lost them but uh
very very well made points
and i um i appreciate them
let's try um why don't we go to sam
from princeton massachusetts not
princeton new jersey
hey david can you hear me yes i can um
so i'll preface this by saying i i sort
of realized that this isn't exactly the
top of like priorities right now okay
but i was just on twitter before i came
in this lobby and i'm seeing
there's lawmakers in some sort of
congressional meeting and i've seen it
going on a little bit i'm talking about
trans people
in athletics and sort of legislating
that
process now i'm on the left
i consider myself to be ardently pro
trans rights and everything but it does
at the same time seemed pretty deeply
unfair to me that
to allow you know people who are born
biologically different to for example
trans women to participate in men's
sports right in women's sports
i mean listen it sounds like we have the
same view i've talked about this before
which is
i have a problem with people that
pretend like this is the big issue the
big injustice that's going on and it
sounds like you're saying the same thing
you recognize this is not like
the biggest issue at the same time when
i think about a sport like weightlifting
or wrestling and i think about someone
born biologically male
and then saying well they now um
they they identify as uh as a woman
and they're going to participate in
wrestling or weightlifting
it strikes me as not making complete and
total sense and this does not in any way
affect the fact that i believe uh trans
folks should be able to live lives
free of discrimination uh they should be
included in
protections when it comes to employment
and should be able to
have a license that reflects their uh
uh gender as as they want to exist in
the world
and yet it just doesn't i just don't
understand how you say
well someone born biologically male can
participate in women's wrestling it
i don't i don't get it i get that you're
not saying it's the most important issue
neither am i it's not even the most
important issue
within trans rights to me there are so
many more important issues within trans
rights
but yeah i'm basically with you i i
would love somebody to explain it to me
yeah i totally and the thing that i that
sort of concerns me is like
because i i watch your show and i watch
other things too and
what the sense that i get is that um i
would be called a transphobe for that
and i'm you know i'm seeing people like
in the majority report and that sort of
thing saying you know
that opinion people are sort of dunking
on like tulsi gabbard for having that
opinion saying she's not really on the
left and i was thinking well i mean i
don't know if that's fair you know
well here's the thing i mean the the
question is
so i i've said before how
you can be in favor of the movement to
boycott israeli products and services
without being
anti-semitic but it also is a great
cover for lots of anti-semitic folks
much the same way you can have this
position or these questions
about uh the the the trans women's
sports issues
and be using it as a cover for your
transphobia
or not you might be a staunch defender
of trans rights and anti-trans
discrimination and still have that
question so it's not a rule that that
you are
or are not transphobic because you are
trying to better understand this issue
as i am
right yeah that's where i see myself so
yeah anyway thanks for uh taking my call
all right my pleasure appreciate the
call very very much
that is all the time we have for today i
apologize i was not able to get to
everybody
but i hope to be able to at some point
in the future
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
did you know the david pakman show is on
all sorts of different platforms find us
on youtube
at youtube.com forward slash the
davidpakmanshow
and on steemit the blockchain based
publishing platform at
steemit.com david pakman
that's s-t-double e mit dot com forward
slash at david pakman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's get into audience
questions first question david
why have opposite why has opposition to
covid guidelines been primarily a
right wing thing in the united states
the in the united states piece is
interesting
i don't know if opposition in other
countries has been from the political
right or not
there has been some covet guideline
opposition
from the left there are some i think
there's a subreddit called like um
liberal lockdown skeptics or something
along those lines but you're absolutely
right that
it's been mostly from the political
right and i think there's a couple
different things going on
first of all there's this sort of
cartoonish idea
of liberty and freedom that exists on
the right
uh more so than it does on the left and
it's not that the left doesn't believe
in liberty and freedom but the left has
a less cartoonish concept of what that
means so
for example on the right things like
liberty and freedom are often assigned
to
i can disregard anyone else's
public health concerns and do whatever
the hell i want that's
freedom and liberty on the right on the
left
we tend to see freedom and liberty more
as
we have the freedom and liberty to live
our lives
working wherever we find it to be most
rewarding
without having to consider whether we
will have health insurance at this job
versus that job that's the kind of
freedom and liberty we talk about on the
left
so obviously that right wing concept of
freedom and liberty
uh is going to lead people down the path
of needing to wear masks
businesses uh restaurants having to be
take out only no no no that's violating
my
my freedom and liberty the other thing
was
certainly trump related and what i mean
by that is
um trump did nothing early and
trump didn't wear masks and trump was
skeptical of what was being done
in different uh in different parts of
the
uh country with regard to certain
governors and so on and so forth so
by definition what trump wanted was
seeing as
seen as the thing for freedom and what
anybody else wanted was seen
seen as a restriction on so-called
freedoms if you were suggesting
something other than what trump was
suggesting or doing
importantly then you were the enemy and
it was bad and you were restricting
people's freedoms
since coronavirus began during the trump
presidency
in an election year there was this
understanding
that anybody suggesting uh something
uh be done differently than what trump
wanted was essentially an indictment of
trump's response
which of course required much indictment
it was one of the worst five responses
in the world according to it to a recent
study
and what continues to get me about that
even now with donald trump gone
is that as much as uh the virus handling
was trump's undoing
it could have guaranteed his re-election
it was a wasted opportunity
trump and the republican party all they
had to do was stand aside
and say what do the experts say oh they
say masks
we're printing american flag masks
we want to get them out to everybody
instead of rejecting the idea of having
the postal service distribute masks to
everybody they could have said yes
the postal service will be bringing
everybody five american flag masks it's
the patriotic thing to do
they could have passed uh uh you know
they could pass
what they passed and more to serve as a
bridge
to dealing with the virus and trump
would have sailed to reelection and
republicans likely would still control
the senate so
the the idea that it had to go the way
it went down political lines with the
anti-massacres and the anti-closures and
guidelines people
uh saying they are violating our freedom
they are treading on us and so on
because of the
tone that was set by trump that was all
optional
however for trump to have handled it
differently would have required trump to
be a different person
the exact same narcissistic tendencies
that are what
a lot of people were drawn to trump by
were what prevented donald trump from
doing what i suggested from the
beginning which is saying
let's do what the doctors say let's be
patriots
it'll be tough but we're all going to do
it together
if trump had sort of bought into that
he wouldn't have been trump in a sense
and that's part of why he was unable to
do it i do think
trump's base would have followed him i
got a few emails saying you know
if trump had done the stuff you're
suggesting his base wouldn't have
followed him
um i think that trump's base was more
than willing to be led
in absolutely any direction at any point
in time
and um it was uh listen
trump would have had a second term had
he dealt with it properly
david do you think washington dc's
strict
gun laws saved lives during the trump
riot
this is a very interesting question it's
really a question that has to be thought
about
in large numbers and what i mean by that
is statistically
dc's gun laws almost certainly saved
some lives let me uh talk talk through
my
sense of it and if you disagree with me
just let me know i know that the gun
people often say gun laws don't stop any
crimes
because the criminals don't follow the
laws anyway
the criminals will find an illegal way
to get a gun
the criminals will bring guns where they
aren't allowed anyway so it doesn't
make a difference and certainly
anecdotally that may well be true to
some degree that may well be true
but there are certainly some
insurrectionists
who opted to leave their firearms at
home
who if the laws were laxer
in dc would have brought guns with them
some of them certainly had guns with
them we know that um
but the number of guns was certainly
lower because of washington dc's
gun laws as a result of that
there are certainly some people who if
they had had firearms with them on that
day in washington dc
could have been uh ending up in some
kind
of a confrontation where either they
would have taken out
drawn or used their firearm or police
may have used one against them by virtue
of seeing that some of these individuals
were
armed so were there people in the
capital with guns
probably yeah probably they were some
would the number have been higher
were the gun laws way more relaxed than
washington dc yeah i think it's
undeniable that more people would have
had guns
and reducing the number of guns in the
situation
removes lowers the probability that
there would have been more
of an escalation um now i know that
there are lots of people saying david a
lot of the people did have guns and they
didn't they didn't use them they didn't
draw them
that's fine but it's merely a numbers
game if you introduce way
more guns into people involved in
violent confrontations physical scuffles
shoving matches and the like
the odds that a gun comes out just goes
up by by virtue of the number of guns
that are that are around
um the the other thing that i think is
important to mention
is a lot of the way that this went down
and there was a very delayed you know we
we we're learning about
the stand down orders that have been
uncovered and a lot of different things
but another aspect to this is that
for a while on january 6th there was the
perception from
many including many in law enforcement
that this was going to be just another
trump rally now they had plenty of
reasons to know it was going to be more
than that and we're exploring whether
that was ignored or
what directives were given but to some
degree some of the people
involved around the event uh thought
this was just going to be another trump
rally and that probably
early on also led to the lack of
response that we saw
had there been more of a response early
on uh
and more guns around i think that
without a doubt
the odds of a gun escalation go go up
dramatically
fortunately there wasn't and i do think
that some role
some role was dc's gun laws and there
are many many ways in which
those gun laws to many people did not
make a difference
hey david you talked about right-wing
dog whistles are their left-wing
dog whistles this is an interesting
question remi you know when we talk
about a dog whistle
a dog whistle is a coded message
that's communicated by using words or
phrases
or even gestures in some way that are
commonly understood by a particular
group of people and not necessarily by
others
so as an example a george soros
and roth the rothschilds that has become
a dog whistle for
anti-semitic tropes about rich usually
jewish men
conspiring to control elements of
government or banking or whatever the
case may be the recent marjorie taylor
green
jewish space laser incident when she
says the rothschilds that
is a dog whistle for people who are
primed
about uh jewish conspiracies to control
this or that industry
to understand that by rothschilds you're
really talking about jews
george soros often when it's mentioned
it means
jews and so that would be example of a
right-wing
dog whistle people some people are
attuned
to listen to it listen for it or to hear
it
globalist is another one which often
also is used to signal we're talking
about
jews now i have some examples of left
wing
maybe what we would call dog whistles
they're pretty lame
and they really don't rise to the level
of the right wing dog whistles the right
uses dog whistles
much more than the left here's a couple
of examples i could think of
sometimes when the left says rural
you could argue that it's a sort of dog
whistle for
like the uneducated hillbilly meme
or caricature sometimes not not always
sometimes there's dog whistling around
suggesting people are racist like for
example
saying someone voted for the crime bill
talking about the 90s crime bill
that could be a pseudo dog whistle to
imply someone is
is racist without saying this is a
racist person
um maybe flyover country
is a dog whistle to suggest that
you know kind of the center of the
country is less
than the so-called liberal coastal areas
the reason that these are kind of weak
is because the left really doesn't
use language in the dog whistle way
that the right does for better or worse
and when i say for worse
we know that the left is terrible at
branding
and to some degree even though the dog
whistling on the right is disgusting in
many cases including stuff like soros
as a catch-all for for jews some of the
dog whistling the right does has been
very effective politically
when it comes to abortion when it comes
to some
religious ideas when it comes to
taxation there are dog whistles
that the right has used successfully i
think they're disgusting and inaccurate
they relate to socialism and life and
all these different things
but the reason that the examples i'm
coming up with for the left uh
the reason that those are lame uh is
that
the left really just doesn't use
language in this way and to some degree
the left has suffered for it the left
has probably
lost what could have been wins in some
cases
because their branding and language is
not as uh
a finely tuned finally operating of a
machine
as the right is if you can think of
left-wing dog whistles
that i've missed certainly let me know
we've got a fantastic bonus show for you
today get instant access to the bonus
show
by becoming a member at joinpackman.com